astronomers have discovered two
supermassive black holes that are on
their way towards a collision with each
other that will rock the very fabric of
space and time
and to that i say
no thank you i don't want anything to do
with this piece of news yeah i don't
want to think about that at all
you see
some news gives me the blues
some news makes me feel pissed
but some news is just so bad baby i
pretend it doesn't exist
i can't get sucked through a hole in the
fabric of space and time and end up back
in the 80s jerry curled you stains your
clothes no no no no thank you
no
that just doesn't exist
some news makes me feel joy
some news fills me with bliss
but some news is just too bad baby i
pretend it doesn't exist like this a new
york man went to the hospital recently
complaining of difficulty breathing and
doctors found a tooth growing inside his
nose
absolutely not no no
worrying about getting cavities inside
your nose teeth
how am i supposed to get a toothbrush up
there now i'm going to pretend like that
news story doesn't exist
is that an exactly healthy approach
nothing i've ever done has ever been
healthy terry davis
that just doesn't exist
[Music]
it doesn't exist like this a nova scotia
couple's three-year-old bulldog gave
birth to a litter of eight puppies and
one of the puppies came out green
how why
does the incredible hulk have a dog we
don't know about
what if this dog gets angry no no no no
no no that just doesn't exist
it doesn't exist
no baby it doesn't exist no no
that just doesn't exist
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you